So who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you 15
seconds to drop so what's our plan hey great
superheroes cannot be allowed to exist
I have no intention to leave my work unfinished
the world's upside down right now
where do we start
that little girl kick your ass
see that wasn't so hard are you just
blink sweet jesus I mean how old are you?
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new falcon and winter soldier trailer they
finally dropped the full trailer so we'll explain
what's going on with all the easter eggs and the
big story lines that they're covering during the
series especially because so much crazy stuff just
happened on Wandavision so i will also explain
some of the connections between Wandavision and
falcon and winter soldier even though they're not
quite as connected as some of the other series
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes so
be sure to subscribe to get all those it'll
be starting march 19th this is the premiere
date it'll air weekly just like Wandavision
but just going through this shot by shot i'll talk
about easter eggs as we go along so obviously they
start with that counseling session they have
the joke about their relationship they have
that funny rivalry but they're also going to be
pretty good friends by the end of this like it's
a joking rivalry but it's not quite the same
type of friendship that both of them have with
captain america they have that same scene of them
jumping at the back of the plane the joke about
falcon not having a plan what's your plan no plan
great bucky getting really pissed off what pisses
you off about him all the night shots of this
really cool crazy looking city or from madrapur
big x-men location in the comics obviously we
just got all the x-men big moments on Wandavision
so i will say careful for spoilers for what
just happened on Wandavision if you haven't
been watching that series we just got evan peters
quicksilver from the fox marvel universe crossing
over and even though it seems like there's more
to his character than meets the eye like it's
not genuinely just quicksilver from the fox x-men
films it's going to be something else too they're
finally integrating fox x-men characters into the
mcu we're finally seeing mutants and x-men show up
so madrapur is just the next big step on the road
to that but the other big x-men easter eggs that
are happening during falcon and winter soldier
are basically through the weapons plus program
which leads up to the weapon 10 weapon x program
eventually the new version of wolverine one of the
major story lines during falcon and winter soldier
is supposed to be them discovering that someone
has resurrected the super soldier serum program in
his creating new super soldiers or attempting to
like baron zemo has the dialogue in the trailer
where he says superheroes should not be allowed
to exist i can't leave my work unfinished we get
the really cool teaser of his comic book costume
with the purple mask we've already seen pictures
of it in earlier teasers but the mission that
he's talking about leaving his work unfinished is
from captain america civil war he was trying to
tear apart the avengers during that but that was
just the beginning of it like he says superheroes
should not be allowed to exist in someone
probably thunderbolt ross maybe somebody else
working with him or trying to resurrect the super
soldier serum program to create a whole bunch
of government-sponsored or government-controlled
superheroes that's more of a thunderbolt storyline
thing too which is one of the other subplots
during this so there's a lot of stuff going on
just like on Wandavision there's so many different
things going on even though sometimes you only see
the surface level stuff in the first couple of
episodes the way they explain it this picks up
pretty much right after the events of avengers end
game which is about where Wandavision picks up too
Wandavision is about three weeks after avengers
end game this will probably be happening within
a similar time span because originally falcon
and winter soldier was meant to be the first
marvel disney plus series to premiere but then
they switched the order and put Wandavision first
you see them trying to exist with a modern
military industrial complex in the united
states like how is everybody dealing with this on
a military level like people like thunderbolt ross
people in control of the military how they change
things after the events of avengers infinity war
and avengers end game you have to imagine
that they would double down hardcore like
we have threats to deal with the whole thing with
Wandavision and sword is that they went for more
of a shield version of nasa mostly just doing a
lot of space missions exploration observing things
trying to protect the earth from extraterrestrial
threats now sword is sentient weapon observation
and response division meaning that they're all
about developing sentient weapons like exploiting
people like vision artificial intelligence
really advanced weapons to protect from what
they perceive as really dangerous threats from
outer space people like thanos showing up again
that gets into the celestials the eternals movie
characters like galactus through the fantastic
four movies obviously there are really dangerous
threats out there but then you see falcon picking
up captain america's shield this looks like some
sort of memorial he's wearing a special suit like
he wouldn't normally be wearing so this is
probably some ceremony for captain america
then you see a slightly different version of him
training with the shield at what looks like maybe
his family's home with winter soldier winter
soldier seems like he catches the shield after
he throws it like he's trying to teach falcon how
to wield it there was the funny spider-man joke
during captain america civil war where he's joking
about captain america shields saying the rumor is
that doesn't obey the laws of physics then
they have the scene of them accepting their
mission to go after baron zemo because he
is the very obvious surface level threat
and you also have the flag smasher villains it
sounds like instead of being a character like
he is in the comics it's actually the name of
an organization like falcon makes fun of winter
soldier now that little girl just beat your ass
she is part of the flag smasher organization
the people with those masks with the hands on
them the whole thing in the comics is the flag
smasher character was all about destroying tearing
down world governments as a way to bring people
together so baron zemo might be working through
that organization but baron zemo is being pitched
as the main villain of the series although it'll
probably be a little more complicated than that
mora falcon in his brand new costume with his
new set of wings using all kinds of trick shots
there are probably multiple versions of the
costume that i'll have during this series
there have been all kinds of toys that have shown
him in a more captain america looking version of
his costume just like they did during the comics
both sebastian stan and anthony mackey have been
talking about how they'll try to explain over
the course of the series who will eventually
become the next version of captain america i
think we can all assume that it's going to be
falcon that's kind of the way they pitched the
series when they first announced it it's just
the way it's all going to play out is going to be
more like a batman battle for the cowl situation
because you have a bunch of different versions of
captain america from the comics people who have
wielded the shield at one point worn the
mantle like at one point bucky was a version
of captain america in the comics at one point
falcon was then you have the us agent version
of captain america that we see during the trailer
footage we get a little bit more footage with him
u.s agent is just meant to be the more hardcore
version of captain america who's much quicker to
use guns much quicker to kill people use lethal
force in a way that captain america tried to
not kill people when he didn't have to he's like
thunderbolt ross's puppet that he gives the shield
to he wants a captain america that he can control
now because he had a big contentious relationship
with the steve rogers captain america and it's
all leading up to him developing the thunderbolts
program i think we'll also see some easter eggs
for that during the black widow movie we finally
see some sharon carter footage with her showing up
surprising both of them at gunpoint then kicking
around a couple villains so it does seem like
she'll actually get some action scenes during this
much bigger than what she got during captain
america civil war we got to see her throw down
a little bit but winter soldier pretty much mopped
the floor with everyone in that scene then they go
on the big joke of their rivalry and them having
the staring contest with the counselor saying how
old are you guys really being a bit of an inside
joke about bucky because he's over a hundred
years old just like captain america although after
avengers end game because of all the time travel
and extra years he put on steve rogers captain
america is now much much older than bucky i know
a lot of people are also asking because they're
bringing back the super soldier serum program
the weapons plus program during falcon and winter
soldier does that mean that falcon will also get
the super soldier serum at some point it's always
possible i haven't seen any rumors about that but
in the comics he doesn't get it he's just regular
falcon in a brand new costume with captain america
shield using the captain america name although
most people still refer to him as falcon i know
there's been a bunch of rumors about chris evans
coming back to reprise his role as steve rogers
they haven't said exactly what that would look
like and i'm not expecting a ton of that during
falcon and winter soldier obviously the series
is a very captain america inspired series so
there'll be a lot of easter eggs and references to
the captain america movies and they did say that
during the series they're going to be bringing
back a bunch of marvel phase 1 deep cut characters
and introducing a bunch of new lore from the
captain america comics anthony mackey also talked
about how they're going to deal with the complex
history behind the idea of captain america in
super soldiers in the mcu's history i think what
he's talking about is the isaiah bradley character
being on the series so obviously in present
day he's a really old character just like
old man steve rogers captain america but the
whole idea is is they used him and his black
regiment in the army as test subjects for the
super soldier serum when they were perfecting it
for the steve rogers captain america so even
though steve rogers cap is billed as the first
version of captain america isaiah bradley was also
kind of a version of captain america before him
but you wouldn't know it because the military at
least within the context of the mcu suppressed
all that information but it is based on a lot of
real-life history like a long time ago the u.s
military really did experiment on black regiments
so they'll have some way of weaving that into the
mcu story like you'll see the true history of the
captain america name not just including the steve
rogers history as captain america the whole thing
with the thunderbolts though is they've already
announced a lot of thunderbolts characters or
potential for thunderbolts across the new disney
plus shows like the abomination would be a great
thunderbolts character he's coming back during the
she-hulk series just like mark ruffalo's hulk is
going to show up during that as well like hulk vs
abomination rematch pretty much any big marvel
villain or super villain that's been locked up
and you haven't seen since save marvel phase 1
or marvel phase 2 it hasn't been confirmed dead
is locked up in the raft by thunderbolt
ross if you're not a big comic book reader
the thunderbolts is basically like marvel's
version of the suicide squad before the black
widow movie had been delayed a billion times
hopefully it still comes out in may and there
are any big issues with that but it could wind up
getting delayed to the summer there were a lot of
us that believed that because it was so much
thunderbolt ross during that and he looked so
weird that we would see easter eggs at least for
him setting up the thunderbolts and for red hulk
thunderbolt ross right now it's kind of hard to
tell which major comic book twist they're going
to save for the movies and what they're going to
do in the disney plus series because they just
had such a huge x-men twist on Wandavision that is
a seismic change in the mcu right now so what'll
happen is is they'll start dropping more footage
for falcon and winter soldier as we get closer
to the Wandavision finale but my Wandavision
episode 6 video with evan peters whole bunch
more quicksilver stuff going on we'll post next
friday i'll be doing videos for a couple of the
other big super bowl trailers as well in the next
couple of days so i'll try to get through those as
fast as possible but leave all your video requests
and big questions in the comments below and all
your predictions for falcon and winter soldier
congratulations m aeon you're the giveaway winner
from my last big marvel video please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for my brand
new Wandavision episode 6 trailer video and click
here for my full Wandavision episode 5 video with
an explanation on what's going on with quicksilver
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!